are you Raava? no but I can help you
find her.
my name is Wan and I will show you how I
became the first avatar.
hey youtubers it's Charlie!
and The Legend of Korra just
aired a two-part episode beginnings and
we found all about the first avatar Wan
how he became the avatar and it answered
a bunch of questions about legend of
korra book 2 as well as the overarching
plot and a lot of the villains so let's
get started let's do a quick recap of
the episode first and then we'll talk
about our favorite moments and what it
means and then i'll do review the
episode the core is taken to lie in some
healing waters so she can reconnect with
her avatar state to keep shouting out
the name raava and we don't know who
that is but while she's in deep
meditation she meets Wan the first
avatar and the rest of the episode
almost takes place entirely in Juan's
perspective we find out that Juan was
actually a thief and lives on the back
of a large lion turtle the lion turtle
actually protects the people from the
spirits in the wild because the spirits
are now living in the human world he
gives them the power of fire every time
they go into the wild to search for food
and whenever they come back they have to
give fire back but because Juan wants to
protect his family he doesn't give the
power fire back he essentially steals
fire just like prometheus and the Greek
mythology the one gets banished but the
lion turtle lets him keep the power of
fire and eventually he learns about the
conflict between raava and vaatu the
spirit of light and spirit of darkness
some accidents may happen and
accidentally vaatu gets away so in order
to atone he basically travels around to
the other lion turtle cities and tries
to learn the other bending abilities he
learns that he's only able to bend other
elements to switch to the other elements
whenever raba passes through him but
they learned during a fight whenever
raava inhabits his body he's actually
able to bend all the elements at the
same time was basically like the Avatar
state but we learned that raava and
vaatu kind of live in this yin-yang
state where as one grows powerful the
other grows weaker and every 10,000
years they have to battle the major
battle that they have is called harmonic
convergence it's actually an event that
happens where both the spirit portals
actually converge during that battle Wan
almost loses but then raava bonds with
his spirit and while that's happening he
sticks his hand in the harmonic convergence essentially bonding himself
to raava for the rest of time that
moment was basically the creation of the
first avatar they trapped vaatu inside
this tree inside the spirit were
old so that he can't get out and then
they closed the spirit portals Wan goes
back into the human world it tries to
maintain the balance between the spirits
and the humans but eventually he ends up dying of old age and raava basically
tells them that their spirits will live
on together forever in each of his
future lives that kind of leaves the
groundwork for the avatar and the
reincarnation cycle where Korra opens
her eyes again and suddenly she
remembers everything and heads back to
the Southern Water Tribe so the episode
basically answered all the big questions
about who the Big Bad was and what the
overarching conflict is and what this
final battle is going to be let's talk
about what it all means, one vaatu is the big bad and he's
obviously been communing with unalaq
over his lifetime trying to gain
strength that's why we see all the dark
spirits so we know that vaatu is
actually responsible for all these dark
spirits and in Locke has just been
laying the groundwork for this harmonic
convergence to happen so he's been
trying to maneuver Korra that's why he had her open the southern
portal she still needs to open the
northern portal in order for this
harmonic convergence to happen in battle vaatu again so this is what she has to
do she basically has to stop vaatu from
escaping 1 and then when harmonic
convergence happens if he does escape
she basically has to trap him again
there are only two more episodes left in
the season episode 9 is called the guide
in episode 10 is called new spiritual
age so obviously episode 10 is where
that battle is going to take place and
it sounds fairly positive so I think we
can safely assume because it was a book
for that Korra is going to win another
interesting thing to note is that Gradle
Isle was actually playing raava we
actually thought that she was going to
be playing the dark spirit or maybe the
big bad but because votchin's voice were
just so deep I think we can safely
assume that she was not playing that
dark spirit obviously because vaatu is
going to be in these last couple of
episodes or maybe just the final episode
we're probably going to see raava again
- or at least here raba speak so we will
get to hear Gradle Isle again isn't it
so funny how she went from playing Azula
the craziest evil character on airbender
to playing the essence of good I'm
really looking forward to the last two
episodes there's actually going to be a
break there won't be an episode next
Friday it'll be in two weeks and then
the finale will air one week after that
but let's talk about our favorite
moments one Steven Yeun's performance
was amazing as Wan I thought it was
great and two people living on the backs
of lion Turtles that was just so funny I
loved that they were the ones that were
actually giving bending to humans but if
you remember that moment in the Oasis
that was there
inspired by spirited away with all the
spirits heading to the bathhouse if you
haven't seen it go see that movie
because it's an amazing Miyazaki film
and let's talk about the amazing
animation on this episode the studio
that did it is actually the studio that
did book one they're using a different
studio to do all of book 2 with the
exception of this episode that's why it
looks so amazing but overall I rate the
episode of the solid a it answered a ton
of questions totally move the story
forward in a really meaningful way kind
of reset chorus character I know a lot
of people have been thinking that she's
been kind of off the rails this season
but I think that now she's kind of back
on the path I loved all the new
characters and I'm really looking
forward to seeing with this new
spiritual ages that they kind of teased
in that final episode but let me know
what your favorite parts were and if
there's anything that you thought was
really important that I didn't mention
in the video be sure to write it in the
comments and we'll totally discuss if I
but now I actually some really big news
for Doctor Who tomorrow they're actually
airing the first trailer for the 50th
anniversary episode technically it's not
footage from the episode it's going to
be an amalgam of a lot of Doctor Who
clips from over the years but it's going
to be the first official BBC 50th
anniversary clip I'll be posting a video
for that right after it airs be sure to
subscribe to get it it's going to be
totally awesome
remember the 50th anniversary is going
to be simulcast on November 23rd don't
forget Walking Dead is on Sunday and
then Monday since there's no Sleepy
Hollow I'll be posting another Game of
Thrones video for Ser Davos if you
really want to help me out please like
and share this video while we wait for
that Doctor Who trailer you can click
here to watch all my other legend of korra
book 2 videos from this year and
you can click here to watch all my other
Doctor Who videos the 50th anniversary
thanks so much watching high fives for Raava